كل من يتعامل في الاسواق المصريه دون ان
يكون مسجلا لدى الحكومه او يدفع ضرائب
يكون منتميا للاقتصاد غير الرسمي الامر
ينسحب على الباعه الجاهلين او على العمال
الذين يعملون كافراد بالاجر اليوميه وفي
بعض الاحيان ينضم اليهم من يقومون ببعض
اعمال الزراعه او التصنيع البسيط او حتى
سائق التوك توك هذه المركبه التي بدات
الحكومه المصريه مؤخرا في اصدار تراخيص
لها في بعض المحافظات حتى تخرج من الظل
الى النور احمد احد السائقين الذين لم
يرخصوا مركبتهم بعد على الوظيفه اللي
جاءتنا المرتب تعبان كنت ما طلعتش اصلا
هو ما اقدرش اطلع بيه بره وكده باشتغل
في القاهره
الترخيص عالي قوي دلوقتي اصلا فاهمني على
صفحات التواصل الاجتماعيه هناك الاف من من
يبيعون منتجات عن طريق توصيلها للمنازل
وهددت الدوله بملاحقتهم كما طلبت من صانع
المحتوى كذلك تسجيل انفسهم لدى السلطات
المصريه لدفع الضرائب
الدكتوره داليا بركات تشرح سبب تفضيل
الملايين للعمل بعيدا عن الاضواء اول حاجه
بيفكر فيها فكره الضرائب مفهوم النظام
الضريبي ده بالنسبه له بعبع انا ايش عرفني
هيفردوا علي غريبه عامله ازاي ممكن ضرائب
بيكون بتتقدر بشكل جذافي اكثر من اللي انا
الدخل اللي بيدخل لي اا الخوف من
البيروقراطيه والاجراءات التكلفه او العيب
ان انا برده همم عشان اروح لها واعمل
الاجراءات دي دراسه درها لرئاسه الوزراء
قدرت ان 60% من حجم الاقتصاد المصريه دوره
بالتوازي في مسار غير الرسميه فلا يسدد
ضرائب ولكن في نفس الوقت يوفر فرص عمل
للملايين فما السبي اقناع هؤلاء بامساك
الدفاتر
ندي له حوافز نشوف الدول المتقدمه زي
الصين سنغافوره عملوا ايه هناك هنشجعكم
على التصدير هتصدر لكم منتجاتكم وهنروج
اكثر لمنتجاتكم فانا لما احس ان انا داخلي
حيزيد بشكل كبير فاكيد بالنسبه لي اللي
انا طبعا اساهم واللي انا ادخل وانضم
الاقتصاد الرسمي وجوده الاقتصاد غير
الرسميه يحرم الموازنه من حصيله ضريبيه
تقدر بنحو 400 مليار جنيه والتي يمكن ان
تغطي ما يقرب من 85% من اجمالي العجز تامر
نصره العربيه القاهره